bonsoir à vous messieurs merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce soir alors les campagnes de
vaccination contre locaux vides 19 se
poursuivent dans plusieurs pays
européens
ce week-end on a entendu un seul arme
der leyen qui s'est félicité d'une
stratégie commune mise en place au
niveau donc européen un moment touchant
d'unité at elle dit et d'histoire de
succès aux européennes est ce qu est la
raison d'être optimiste je me tourne
vers vous à didier guillemot écoutez je
crois qu'on peut être optimiste et
surtout extrêmement impressionné des
progrès des animations de noël qui ont
été faites un petit peu de temps mais je
crois que ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que la fraude si jack six nations
là est destiné à protéger les personnes
les plus vulnérables et non à diminuer
la circulation du virus à ce stade et de
ce que vous observez
il ya une vraie stratégie européenne
commune tout de même très délégué tard
qu'en pensez vous je pense qu'il ya
d'abord je rejoins ce qu'a dit le
président de l'om est c'est à dire que
c'est vraiment une mine le vaccin qui va
nous sortir de cette situation et que
c'est vraiment une prouesse
technologique il faut quand même saluer
d'avoir développé avec ça en moins d'un
an j'avais que le premier cas qui a été
officielle en chine c'était le 27
décembre de mai 2019 et le vaccin arrive
juste un an après donc on voit qu à elle
que ces véritables ans sur les progrès
médicaux on était absolument fantastique
et je crois qu'il faut les saluer
ensuite il ya moi personnellement je ne
suis pas convaincu par la stratégie
européenne de vacciner d'abord les plus
fragiles parce que je crois qu'il faut
avoir une vision sur le moyen terme
c'est-à-dire jusqu'au moment de
l'obtention de l'immunité collective
c'est à dire 60 à 70% de la population
immunisés et il faut avoir eu aussi une
approche transversale pas simplement
médical sur un plan médical il n'y a pas
de doute qu'il faut commencer par les
plus fragiles
sur un plan de santé publique quand vous
mettez l'aspect éthique économique
sociale et médicale
je ne suis pas convaincu et je pense que
l' approche asiatiques -les approche
américaine et la proche anglaise me
paraissent plus convaincante d'essayer
d'avoir un mix entre des personnes
fragiles et des personnes exposées
parce que le risque il est double il est
d'être exposés au virus c'est-à-dire
d'attraper le virus et que vous
développiez une forme grave donc les
plus fragiles les plus fragiles dans les
ehpad sont le deuxième risque le plus
élevé
n'est on pas le premier risque le plus
élevé le premier jeu le plus élevé il
est temps ce qui qui se mouche qui ont
une vie sociale et économique
alors c'est vrai didier guillemot la vie
de l'épidémiologiste pourquoi est-ce
qu'en france
en europe on ne vaccine pas à grande
échelle massivement on le fait au
royaume uni on voir en russie notamment
pourquoi s en france et en europe on ne
le fait pas mais je pense que c'est un
choix qui a été fait au regard de la
vulnérabilité des gens dire que moi je
ne partage pas complètement l'avis de m
en hauteur lecteurs c'est à dire qu' on
ne peut pas escomptée à ce stade
évidemment obtenir très rapidement une
immunité collective suffisante pour
ralentir la circulation de dieuze par
ailleurs on ne sait pas si au delà de la
diminution des personnes infectées
si le vaccin a un impact sur
l'expression orale
à partir de là la bonne stratégie et à
mon avis effectivement de vacciner les
gens qui sont au plus haut risque
d'infection
alors justement le en france le
gouvernement espère 15 millions
d'immuniser d'ici l'été
là encore cette question est ce que
c'est un objectif tenable et réaliste on
se souvient en plus fort de la crise
sanitaire les couacs les polémiques même
autour des équipements pour les
personnels soignants les masques aussi
la période où on a commencé à tester
c'était un peu confus tout cela fait
dériver izard mais pour être honnête
d'abord je pense qu'il ya un devoir de
réussite
donc je pense que toute remarque analyse
doit elle doit être fait dans un sur un
plan constructif parce qu'on a vraiment
tous un devoir de réussite de cette
campagne de vaccination et moi je pense
même qu'il faut véritablement une union
nationale sur un plan politique qu'on
n'a pas eue
peut-être que le gouvernement l'a pas
assez recherché je vois une opposition
qui essaient d'un peu de d'utiliser sa
la vaccination à des fins politiciennes
là je pense qu'on est vraiment sur un
territoire très dangereux quand il faut
être dans un objectif d'être constructif
parce que j'aimerais voir davantage ces
implants davantage de structures et plus
structurée sur combien de personnes est
ce qu'on est capable de vacciner par
mois et comment est-ce qu'on va
atteindre cet objectif
je voyais un objectif par exemple en
israël qui était de 150 mille
vaccination par semaine et moi je trouve
intéressant de se fixer des objectifs
comme ça pour que toutes les ressources
qui sont quand même diverses pour être
vaccinées soit véritablement tendue sur
un objectif quantitatif réaliser donc là
je crois qu'on manque un petit peu de
visibilité et et et 2 et d'objectifs
quantifiés l'objectif déjà de ses dires
c'est un objectif déjà de se dire qu'on
souhaite atteindre 15 millions
d'immuniser d'ici l'été
excusez moi mais c'est difficile quand
même à faire redescendre à l'échelle du
terrain pour savoir très exactement on
voit que ça commence vraiment de façon
très très longtemps alors peut-être que
c'est une peut-être que c'est
stratégique au 6 mai mais je le vois là
quand on discute avec des médecins
généralistes on voit que ce n'est pas
très clair chez eux quelle va être leur
rôle mais on dit tout va dépendre du
rôle du médecin généraliste
un dernier point qui semble essentielle
pourquoi je pense que la première cible
devraient être les professionnels de
santé comme c'est le cas aux états unis
c'est parce que je pense qu'il peut en
faire des ambassadeurs je crois que les
1 million 500 mille professionnels de
santé qui sont en france une partie
d'abord est relativement fragile et donc
dans le coeur de cible des gens à
protéger mais surtout il faut vraiment
que ces professionnels
qui sont en première ligne soient les
premiers protéger et soient les premiers
ambassadeurs de ce vaccin n'oublions pas
qu'on est un pays avec une grande
défiance de la vaccination du fait des
erreurs en 2009 du fait d'une défiance
de la parole publique donc plus les
pelles et les politiques défendre le
vaccin plus il ya un risque inverse
qu'on ait des vaccins qu'ils soient vues
par la population avec un un petit peu
un doute
donc voila moi je crois que ce sont les
professionnels de santé les principaux
ambassadeurs
mais alors c'est sa tanière pour votre
réaction à didier guillemot devrait vous
entendrez également sur les objectifs
fixés par le gouvernement à savoir si
ces 15 millions démunis zi s'il était en
voyage pour ce que c'est absolument
raisonnable un cercle
il faut pas oublier qu'il y a derrière
des questions de capacités de production
ce qui tue accents qu'il y a aussi
d'autres éléments qui sont survenus avec
la souche anglaise enfin la sanction
trop guillemets qui se diffuse une autre
alerte sur une sphère variant en
australie donc on va être évidemment
confrontés à de nouveaux événements du
point de vue de la circulation du virus
donc pour l'instant je pense que la
question vraiment importante
c'est le protéger les gens qui sont les
plus susceptibles de faire des formes
graves de l'infection et que
la question de lutter contre la
diffusion des virus
évidemment se pose mais il faut
certainement là réfléchir avec
circonspection et je pense que nous
allons arriver petit à petit à des
stratégies d'action plus régionaliser
voire plus localisées on voit que les
premiers problèmes avec le début de
cette campagne de vaccination au niveau
européen
les livraisons par exemple de vaccins à
destination de huit pays européens qui
ont accusé un léger retard c'est un
problème qui a été réglé mais en cause
des problèmes logistiques à lui
d'insider en belgique dont la parlais
tout à l'heure dans ce cas précis de
compte est quand même particulier crise
sanitaire est ce que ces problèmes
logistiques ils sont acceptables
frédéric dard c'est je pense une
contrainte qui est lié moi je les lis
déjà un certain nombre de semaines où il
ya juste un goulot d'étranglement qui
sont les enzymes ya trois type d'enzymes
nécessaires pour produire des vaccins
arn messagers ces enzymes sont
extrêmement difficiles à produire en
kilos de façon expérimentale on les
produits en mg et là c'est même pas en
mg 100 g c'est en kg
donc on sait qu'il ya ce goulot
d'étranglement qui qui qui fait que
finalement toutes les annonces qui ont
été faites par les laboratoires son
texte excessivement optimiste donc là on
est à un retour à la réalité où on voit
que ce qui avait été prévu
elle n'est pas la réalité qu'il faut
probablement diviser par deux selon ce
que l'on prévoit donc ça c'est là on est
dans vraiment la réalité le sais ce qui
me paraît important et là il ya une
forte incertitude c'est le vaccin
adénovirus d'astrazeneca lé
véritablement c'est lui qui peuvent est
vraiment changé la donne parce qu'on est
capable de produire là pour le coup
beaucoup plus rapidement sans avoir le
problème des matières premières dernier
point ça a été dit par monsieur guy mots
mais c'est très important
c'est cette notion de de mutation du
virus qui tue ta phénomène normal ça
jure rendent pas dans la dans le domaine
d expertise monsieur guillaume etc est
un phénomène qui est normal quand on
regarde un petit peu ce qui se passe en
revanche en revanche on voit que là on
est à la troisième fille pleine mutation
mais en tout cas la troisième mutation
entre les vies
du danemark lors ce qui s'est passé en
angleterre en afrique du sud
et là ça pose quand même la question de
savoir si on va pas perpétuellement
courir après ce virus d'une part et
d'autre part si apparemment si les plus
si c'est plus contagieux puisque les
formes mutantes ont l'air d'être plus
contagieux si si ça va pas nécessiter
encore une fois un retard dans le retour
à la vie normale puisque là c'est plus
60% de la population qui devrait être
utilisé mais peut-être 80 % de la
population dans ces eaux là c'est quand
même un élément vincent ce virus mutant
et toutes les formes mutante du virus
justement on a plus de problèmes liés à
la contagion mais peut-être pas plus de
dangerosité et d'idées guillemot et en
plus au niveau européen on affirme que
ce fameux bac sans fin et leur viande
est qu'il est efficace
qu'en pensez vous alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que il ya 2000 à sion qui sont
protégés que les gens commencent
maintenant à comprendre et à connaître
qui pose problème et je dirais que le
problème principal n'est pas tant la
question de la dangerosité ou regard de
la célérité d'infection a priori rien ne
va dans ce sens peut-être dans le sens
d'une transmission un peu plus
importante mais ça ça risque
ça reste à confirmer moi ce que je pense
à ce que tout le monde craint c'est
évidemment qu'il y ait une divergence
qui fasse que les vaccins actuels ne
puisse pas agir sur la prévention de
l'infection à ces nouveaux virus et la
crainte évidemment c'est qu'on se
retrouve dans un certain temps avec
quelques clones qui circulent sur la
planète et qui est suffisamment
divergences pour nécessité de faire
évoluer les taxant les contenus
l'accident et je crois que
il faut envisagé assez sérieusement
cette perspective et non pas rester avec
l'idée qu'on va courir derrière mais
plutôt avec l'idée qu'il va falloir
qu'on s'adapte à l'évolution du graal
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait depuis un
an on l'a souligné l'un et l'autre avec
les programmes d'innovation mais c'est
de l'adaptation l'évolution du virus
est-ce qu'il a évidemment nécessité des
surveillances un probablement plus
organisée du point de vue de la
surveillance génétique du virus puisque
vous parlez aussi de prévention il ya
quand même des mesures de restrictions
sanitaires importantes en europe et en
france on parle même de reconstituer on
verra cela demain à l'issue d'un conseil
de défense sanitaire
justement ces campagnes de vaccination
et se poursuit dans ce contexte de
restriction est ce que c'est compatible
finalement on subit un sur la puisque et
là on a d'ailleurs des leçons qu'il
faudra tirer puisque la france reste un
pays extraordinairement fort sur le soin
et sur la médecine individuelle mais on
voit bien qu'on est très très défaillant
sur la médecine des populations et sur
la santé publique donc moi je pense il
ya quand même des des leçons à tirer et
vraiment des d'enseignement on voit
qu'on a mis 8 milliards à l'hôpital mais
n'a pas mis un seul centime sur la santé
publique
monsieur guillemot a parfaitement raison
de dire qu'il ya il ya des choses à
craindre à venir mais mais on n'est pas
obligé simplement des craintes qu'il
faut probablement investir massivement
dans les technologies qui vont permettre
de peut-être créer le vaccin universel à
coronavirus en tout cas on voit bien que
ce vaccin arn messager il est quand même
assez extraordinaire de sa capacité à
pouvoir s'adapter à des mutations
beaucoup plus facilement je parle sous
le contrôle institut pasteur mais que
les vaccins adénovirus donc h donc moi
je pense qu'il faut tout ça ça fait
partie des des côtés des choses pendant
des connaissances qu'on engrange mais
l'europe et la france devrait à mon avis
est assez moteur dans l'investissement
pour aller vers une protection
définitive de cette famille de virus un
virus
or justement didier - est-ce que
pourquoi on diversifie pas justement
visages des vaccins ce n'est pas
possible au niveau européen diversifié
je n'ai pas vraiment compris votre
question je veux gagner voilà précisiez
élargir par exemple ya le vaccin phison
biotech qui est utilisée on a
l'impression qu'un monopole devoir faire
il ya d'autres vaccins non mais c'est
tout simple c'est que les autres
rassemblent n'ont pas fait l'objet de
deux lattes approval enfin d'agrément
des auteurs italiens du médicament de la
vie et de l'agencé du médicament
européenne et on ne peut pas mettre avec
ça alors même qu'on a pas démontré son
efficacité à prévenir la fiction et
surtout avec suffisamment d'éléments
pour être au mieux sur que l'accent est
sûre et qui aura pas d'effets
secondaires que c'était la question de
jean et c'était 2 est ce qu'on voit pas
mutualiser les ressources et à dire que
moi j'avais suggéré faire un airbus de
vaccins
je pense que l'europe redevenir
véritablement une tête de pont de ces
technologies vaccinale qui ont valu on
le voit sont des technologies qui sont
fait partie du soft power du 21e siècle
et je pense que si on mutualisaient si
on unisep de force de grands pays comme
la france l'allemagne peut-être la
suisse pour véritablement densifier
cette recherche et et mieux protéger la
population et accéléré et je dirais les
novations vaccinale à mon avis ça
pourrait avoir un sens oui mais vous
savez bien que dans la recherche il ya
aussi toujours des facteurs de paris à
l'évidence l'industriel pfizer n'a pas
fait le même parmi que d'autres causes
de ce real notamment des industriels qui
sont plus proches de nous en france et
c'est pas c'est le par une faveur qui a
fonctionné en même temps que le paris
moderne au moins à ce stade
donc on peut mettre évidemment beaucoup
d'argent mais ça ne m'arrive pas les
choix et les parvis stratégiques qui
sont faites en domaine développement
industriel et je suis pas certain que ce
soit en faisant des gros machin même des
airbus qu'on n'arrive à résoudre ce
problème il faut des hommes et des
hommes qui est des esprits
entrepreneuriaux sur le savez bien
énergie dernière question mais une
dernière question avec cette campagne ce
lancement de campagne la campagne de
vaccination au niveau européen on a vu
aussi une campagne de médiatisation
justement pour lutter contre une
certaine défiance vis-à-vis du dieu du
vaccin notamment finder obiang tech
il ya même des hommes politiques qui se
sont fait vacciner devant les caméras
est-ce que ça c'est utile véritablement
cette médiatisation pour convaincre
l'opinion publique par rapport au niveau
de défiance de la parole publique et les
politiques en france je crois qu'il faut
être assez prudent
moi je pense que c'est là la valeur
d'exemple est importante donc je pense
que tu étais personnalités politiques
comme des personnalités qui ont une
influence sur l'opinion publique de sas
a un intérêt à ce que la soie je pense
qu'ils vont pas passer à une phase de
théâtralisation pour la raison que vous
évoquez mais là vous voyez qu'en france
on est moi je suis assez assez stupéfait
de voir qu'on est à là on est peut-être
à la marge une utilisation politicienne
de la défiance vaccinale où on voit une
opposition qui est un petit peu qui va
un petit peu très prudemment alors que
encore une fois mais on a aussi un
pouvoir qui a déposé un chemin un projet
de loi à un peu maladroitement laissant
entendre qu'on allait lille
la vaccination à l'accès à un certain
nombre de l'espace public donc moi je
pense qu'il faut vérifier il ya un tel
devoir de réussite à l'échelle
individuelle et collective de cette
campagne de vaccination qu'il faut
vraiment rechercher
peut-être qu'on la trouvera pas mais une
union nationale pour qu'on soit plutôt
meilleurs que les autres dans cette
campagne
didier guillemot le mot de la fin pour
vous si oui moi je pense que la question
de la vaccination obligatoire
d'abord des pannes question neuve lcl
existent pour un centre de vaccins enfin
la seule manque aucune part dans
certains pays mais surtout je pense
qu'il ne faut pas les luttes et c'est à
dire que on peut aboutir comme je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure des stratégies
à ces régionales mans ciblées de
contrôle vouloir de vaccination mais des
stratégies qui pourraient être un peu
dur pour éviter justement que don de
l'argent pour les prendre suffisamment
tôt et éviter qu'ils ne diffusent trop
largement donc évidemment tout le monde
a compris qu'il y avait une grande
maladresse dans la manière dont le
gouvernement avait présenté les choses
mais par contre évidemment qu'il ne faut
pas balayer d'un revers de main la
question
merci beaucoup à tous les deux des démos
épidémiologiste à l'institut pasteur et
fredrik bizarre économiste spécialiste
santé